bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur 9 7 4 TV
l'émission du Conseil Général des Jeunes
aujourd'hui je suis en présence de
samiriteur le Président du Conseil
Général des Jeunes mélissarantes
vice-présidente du Conseil Général des
Jeunes Priscilla Lefebvre présidente de
la commission Nord et Ilona beauvalo
vice-présidente de la Commission Nord
donc aujourd'hui nous allons parler d'un
thème qui est la solidarité donc je
pense qu'en premier nous allons définir
ce qu'est la solidarité pour chacun
d'entre vous ça mérite
se soutenir les uns les autres donc
c'est un lien fort qu'on peut avoir
entre amis entre la famille et même des
étrangers donc un lien fort qui pousse à
nous entraider des uns des autres
d'accord
pour moi la solidarité c'est avoir du
soutien pour les personnes qui nous
entourent et c'est aussi sentir le
besoin des autres et les aider
alors pour moi c'est se battre pour un
événement ou une cause qui ne compte et
c'est un sentiment qui pousse l'homme à
s'accorder à une amie mutuelle
pour moi la solidarité c'est en quelque
sorte prendre l'initiative de faire
avancer les choses de faire évoluer les
esprits sans pour autant en attendre au
retour
d'accord donc au cours de notre
mandature cette année nous avons pu
faire plusieurs actions qui étaient en
rapport elle-même avec la solidarité
est-ce qu'il y en a qui vous ont marqué
vive moi-même j'ai eu l'occasion de
participer
à la manifestation au CREPS de
Saint-Paul avec des enfants de vie du
centre de la ressource qui ont des
handicaps auditifs et visuels
avec on a participé à des ateliers
créatifs tels que la fresque qu'on a
créé avec ses enfants
ça a été un réel plaisir de les voir
s'amuser et rire sans pour autant se
préoccuper de
ces différences
et pour leur plaisir des artistes locaux
m'ont voulu participer tels que MC Eric
ING ou media et ça a été vraiment une
magnifique journée d'accord alors au
sein du Conseil Général des Jeunes le 6
mai 2014 nous avons fait une journée de
sensibilisation pour l'environnement
partenariat avec le NF on a fait une
flash mob où on a fait une chaîne
humaine en forme d'arbre
nous avons confié convié tous les
collèges de Lille ou et avec ce qui ont
répondu présent nous avons fait une
marche jusqu'au Colorado et lors du
flash mob j'étais très contente de voir
tous ces collégiens se donner à fond
pour l'environnement
moi dans le cadre du Conseil Général des
Jeunes j'ai assisté au concours
d'éloquence du collège Jean d'est le 20
mars dernier
les élèves qui ont participé on récitait
un poème qu'ils avaient écrit eux-mêmes
ou avec leur classe ils étaient tous
motivés là pour moi était tous
différents et très originaux
j'ai pu voir que la solidarité pour eux
c'était très important et qu'ils étaient
contents de s'exprimer sur ce sujet
le Conseil Général des Jeunes donc a
participé à une action à réaliser une
action de solidarité le 14 avril 2014 à
la SPA de Sainte-Marie et du tampon et
donc le but de cette action était de
sensibiliser les personnes ayant des
animaux domestiques car bien sûr à la
réunion nous avons un trop grand nombre
d'animaux qui sont délaissés maltraités
et même tués sur les voies publiques
donc la SPA est régulièrement surcharge
d'animaux donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle le Conseil Général des Jeunes
donc a réalisé un don de solidarité à
titre personnel bien sûr en offrant des
croquettes et des pâtés pour chats et
donc ce qui est important aussi c'est
que les jeunes ont pris conscience que
les animaux donc sont des êtres vivants
et aussi nos amis
donc vous avez pu voir que avec le
Conseil Général des Jeunes l'axe phare
de cette année était la solidarité mais
bien sûr nous avons fait d'autres
actions en parallèle comme par exemple
le concours de slam qui s'est déroulé à
Champfleury le 17 juin 2014 ou plusieurs
collèges ont été conviés et différentes
élèves de ses collègues ont pu exposer
leurs talents devant un public
oui le concours slam a permis de donner
la parole aux jeunes ça leur a permis
aussi de s'exprimer devant devant un
public et sur une scène et pour un bon
nombre d'entre eux c'était la première
fois oui ça va exactement donc en fait
donc moi-même j'étais présent donc en
tant que jury
au concours de slamine dans urbaine donc
j'ai pu voir donc en tant que jury qu'il
y avait vraiment beaucoup de talents
cachés dans certains collèges et même
dans tous et ben vraiment c'était
vraiment une magnifique journée vraiment
une grande manifestation qui ont
rassemblé plus de 25 collèges de Lille
c'est vrai c'était une très bonne
journée donc nous avons pu voir que
grâce à toutes ces actions qui ont été
préparées minutieusement par notre
référente Jesse Robert le Conseil
Général des Jeunes nous a apporté
beaucoup de choses au cours de ces deux
ans
et nous en sommes vraiment
reconnaissants vous souhaitez partager
qui vous apporter
pour moi donc le Conseil Général des
Jeunes m'a beaucoup apporté sur le prend
sur le plan professionnel et sur le plan
personnel donc maintenant donc je peux
m'exprimer vraiment en public et avec
une avec une aisance incroyable et
donc mais nous avons pu même nous jeunes
monter des des projets et puis bien sûr
on a réalisé j'ai réalisé des rencontres
des rencontres avec bien sûr le préfet
de la Réunion alors que même en tant que
jeune sans être président sans être dans
le Conseil Général des Jeunes je
n'aurais pas pu faire vraiment de belles
rencontres
moi aussi j'ai rencontré des personnes
vraiment que je n'aurais jamais
rencontré en dehors j'ai compris
qu'est-ce que c'était le travail de
groupe
maintenant je suis plus à l'aise devant
un public et ça m'a permis d'être plus
assidu et plus responsable parce que je
me suis engagée pour deux ans
alors le Conseil Général des Jeunes m'a
été à m'exprimer en public à être en
contact avec les autres et de faire de
très bonnes rencontres au cours de cette
année avec les autres conseillers
généraux
moi ce monde de 2 ans m'a permis de me
responsabiliser dans la vie de tous les
jours de faire de magnifiques rencontres
et je dois dire que c'était une très
belle expérience
pareil pour moi ça le Conseil Général
des Jeunes ça m'a montré que même si on
est jeune ben on peut quand même ça on
peut enfin on peut s'investir dans une
institution et avoir des responsabilités
s'engager et puis c'est vrai que ça nous
a fait de belles rencontres aux quatre
coins de l'île de la Réunion alors
franchement c'était vraiment une belle
expérience et puis aussi et puis aussi
ce que je voulais dire aussi c'est qu'il
faut vraiment donc remercier notre
responsable madame Jesse Robert qui
était là pour nous qui a aussi donc
œuvré donc pour réaliser nos projets et
vraiment nous sommes vraiment
reconnaissants envers et
même si on est triste de quitter le
Conseil Général des Jeunes parce que
deux ans ça passe extrêmement vite et
qu'on n'a pas on n'a pas pu réaliser
toutes les actions qu'on avait prévues
on compte sur la nouvelle mandature
l'année prochaine pour nous aider enfin
pour réaliser ce qu'on avait commencé et
on souhaite vraiment remercier de tout
notre cœur madame Jessie Robert
et voilà merci de votre écoute et à la
prochaine sur 9 7 4 TV